قبل ايام ماتت عميده البشريه رهيبه فرنسيه
عن عمر يبلغ 118 عاما مع وفاتها زاد
الحديث عن اعمار البشر والى اي مدى يمكن
الانسان ان يعمر والصوره باختصار العالم
يشيخ الناس تعيش اكثر وبات السن التقاعد
ازمه على امتداد العالم واليوم تشير
تقارير سكانيه الى انقلاب القنبله
السكانيه في كثير من الدول لدرجه ان دول
كبرى مثل الصين صارت تدعو سكانها الانجاب
بعد سنوات من العزوف عن ذلك الامم المتحده
اعلنت في تقرير الاخير لها انه بحلول
منتصف القرن الحالي ستكون دول افريقيا
الجنوبيه وحدها قادره على منزل العالم
بالشباب بينما ستعاني القارات الاخرى من
زياده معدلات الاكبر سناك هذه الازمه
اصبحت اليوم قنبله موقوته ما ينعكس بشكل
سلبي على موازنات الدول وسط غياب الحلول
الحقيقيه للاسماك
[موسيقى]